ما الذي تعرفه أن هذا كان
تصميمًا تجريبيًا ولا شك
في أنه مركب من الكربون،
يمكنك أن تخبرنا المزيد عما يعنيه ذلك
في الواقع، أعني أنه نوع
الأشياء المستخدمة في المركبات الفضائية ولكن هل هو
مصمم للضغط العميق تحت الماء
وماذا؟  هو ما هو خطر
هذا النوع من المواد في هذا النوع من
البيئة،
فهو غير مناسب تمامًا للسفينة
التي تتعرض لضغط خارجي،
كما تعلمون، يتم استخدام مركبات ألياف الكربون
بنجاح كبير جدًا
لأوعية الضغط الداخلية مثل دعنا نقول
خزان سكوبا و  يمكنك الحصول على ضعف أو
ثلاثة أضعاف ما يمكن أن
تحصل عليه من الفولاذ أو الألومنيوم مقابل
هذا النوع من زجاجات الضغط ولكن بالنسبة
لشيء يشهد
ضغطًا خارجيًا، تختفي جميع مزايا
المواد المركبة وتظهر جميع
العيوب في الاعتبار، لذا  إذا
كنت تستخدم مادة موحدة مثل
الفولاذ أو التيتانيوم أو السيراميك أو
الأكريليك، فيمكنك عمل نماذج حاسوبية بدرجة
عالية من الدقة
والثقة في اللحظة التي تبدأ فيها في عمل
مركب الكربون أو أي نوع من
المواد المركبة التي تقدمها
المواد التي تتلامس مع
بعضها البعض، الخيوط نفسها ثم
مصفوفة الإيبوكسي التي تتوضع
بداخلها، وعند هذه النقطة يكون لديك
فشل في التحلل، لذلك
فهمنا دائمًا أن هذه كانت
المادة الخاطئة للثقوب الغاطسة لأنه
مع كل دورة ضغط يمكنك  لديك
ضرر تدريجي، لذا فهو
غدرا تمامًا لأنه قد يكون لديك عدد
من عمليات الغطس الناجحة وهو ما
حدث هنا ثم تفشل
لاحقًا،
حسنًا، نريد أيضًا أن نشير إلى
المدير السابق للعمليات البحرية في Ocean Gate،
فقد كتب هذا
التقرير الهندسي في عام 2018.  أعتقد أنه ركز
انتقاداته على قرار الشركة
الاعتماد على المراقبة الصوتية
للأصوات التي يصدرها الهيكل تحت الضغط
بدلاً من مسح القاعة
وفقًا له أه الشركة ادعت
عدم وجود معدات يمكنها إجراء
هذا النوع من المسح على
السيارة التي يبلغ سمكها 5 بوصات مصنوعة من ألياف الكربون بسمك 5 بوصات،
أعلم أنه من الصعب القول
بوضوح دون قراءة التقرير ولكني
أتساءل ما الذي تفهمه من ذلك
لأنه يبدو أن هذه
الشركة كانت تعقد صفقة كبيرة بشأن
أجهزة الاستشعار التي تمتلكها  هل يمكن أن تعرف وجود
مشكلة في الهيكل، وإذا كان
بإمكانهم ذلك نظرًا لوجود مشكلة،
فسيكون لديهم الوقت للاستدارة
والعودة للأعلى بوضوح أنهم
لم يفعلوا ذلك، فالأمر يشبه إلى حد ما
القول بأن لدينا
القليل من  تصميم سيئ للمحرك في
طائرتنا أو سفينتنا الصاروخية ولكن لدينا
جهاز استشعار سيخبرنا إذا كانت النار مشتعلة
بالنسبة لي، فهذا ما يسمى الراحة وأعتقد
أنه إذا كنت تقوم ببناء قاعة
حيث تحتاج إلى ذلك  لديك أجهزة استشعار لإخبارك
أنه فشل في عملية
الفشل، وليس لديك عمل في تصميم
الغواصات أو التواجد في ذلك الجزء الفرعي الذي
روجوا له، وأعتقد أنك تعرف أنه شيء
جيد
كبروتوكول أمان ولكني أعتبره  وهو أمر سيء
لأنه يلقي الضوء بشكل مباشر
على الخلل الأساسي في
تصميمهم
الأجنبي